Hello Freak bitches
did Twitter.
But are you,
oh,
I love Twitter.
I love it.
And I know that I'm a giant bitch on there and I don't do your I am you a bitch
always telling people to go fuck themselves.
Oh wait.
It's like,
because it's so enjoyable to me.
It's like playing a game and I,
you know,
the part of me is like,
I hate that part of myself,
but I also really like it because I think I'm be coming.
It's to me it's not,
I'm not a brand.
There's no Julie Kedsey fighter who has to impress anybody anymore like it.
You know,
there's a,
granted I represent invicta to a certain extent,
but I know I fully understand that Shannon could fire me if I say something just
outrageous and horrible.
She wouldn't,
she's a wonderful person and I'm no longer at behind the scenes there.
I'm just,
I'm a commentator.
I'm not somebody making any decisions with the company.
Right.
But I don't know,
when it comes to Twitter,
what do you do?
You get in flame wars with people,
some street shit too.
Kind of enjoy when people insult me.
And I go after.
Yeah.
But I do feel my brain deteriorating a little bit when they do that.
You know,
it was just like I'm an I.
I was just like,
okay,
I need to stop me to put this down now.
But you know,
when they come at me,
they're just like,
you're a Feminazi your those who I'm just looking at,
come on.
I know.
Feminazi I'm very outspoken,
being a feminist.
I'm very,
uh,
you know,
and when I talk about socialism,
when I talk about I hate Donald Trump and I talk about this,
you know,
yeah,
I know,
but I would never label you in like,
you're just a genuine person.
Like who happens to be a woman who believes what you believe.
Like you,
you're not like sexist.
You're not like anti male or anytime
men.
I love men,
but the thing is I am pro woman to certain sent me when it comes to MMA,
I'm,
I'm more interested in what's going on with women in the sport then with men.
That's just where I'm oriented.
That's,
that's my part of your job.
And,
um,
but,
well,
I don't know.
There's this association,
they'll,
first of all,
the whole Feminazi label is just,
I mean that's the first thing.
Like I said,
yeah,
I'm really proud to be a feminist.
And then people are just know that means you hate men.
You think they're all rapists?
And I'm like,
no,
that discredits men so much.
Like why?
No.
Well,
it's silly.
And that though the term feminist has been so cooptive by negative thoughts.
So many people have this negative connotation they attached to it of course.
And Its movements that,
you know,
third wave [inaudible] this and you know,
there's certain when whenever appeal fucking problem,
male feminists,
they've ruined it.
Those fucking twats men ruin everything they've read.
Even ruined feminine.
That's funny.
I know,
I know Jamie was on here and he was a friend of mine in some weird happened with
that guy.
I don't know what's going on with his life right now.
But Jamie Kilstein.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Not Good.
I don't know what's going and I don't want to speculate on any of that.
But we were really good friends for a while and you know,
they,
I know his like he was very disliked as a male feminist,
quote unquote male thing.
Well it's because everybody thought that he was when he just got accused of
being right and they're just Coonhounds that are taking that angle.
I I that is an interest.
I honestly think sometimes people are just assholes who want sex.
And I also think people are manipulative assholes who want sex.
I don't see him as a manipulative person,
but again,
I might
probably not,
I didn't interact.
Yeah,
I don't know either.
You know,
I don't,
I think people are a bunch of different things depending on who they are,
what time of the day.
I think it'd be nice if the whole world was egalitarianism and if we all looked
at the people as just treating them,
who they are based on their character and their personality and not categorizing
them.
So specifically like,
oh you are a woman so you are less or you are a man and you are
or,
or vice averse male feminist.
And it's like that's the problem.
I mean,
are you joking when you said
no?
I mean,
yeah,
it's,
the problem is there's a lot of people that virtue signal and a lot of people
that are posturing and a lot of people that are putting a label on themselves to
try to make themselves seem like they're in a higher moral high ground than the
rest of the folks around them,
and that's the motivation for doing it.
That becomes transparent and people get angry at that.
They recognize what it is.
So when someone like Jamie Kilstein slips up after all these years of virtual
signaling,
they're like,
ah,
I knew it.
Fuck,
here's that.
Does that really negate some of the good things that he's done?
If he's influenced some men?
I don't know the virtue.
I guess one of the good things,
I don't know if he's maybe said,
oh,
hey,
a woman is actually a person.
It's absolutely fall.
The fuck doesn't think a woman has a personal Twitter timeline.
Let me tell you something.
Those people cool.
If there's a person out there that doesn't think that a woman's a person fucking
Jamie Kilstein is not going to change their opinion.
It's just going to,
he's just going to broadcast it and let everybody know that's how he thinks and
he's going to get all this love and people are going to send him all these likes
and they're going to give them thumbs up and say nice things to him on Twitter
and that may or may not be a good thing.
It's more a good thing that a bad thing.
It's not a bad thing,
but you're not going to change some asshole opinion saying something like that.
I don't know that you are,
but I,
I don't know.
Have you changed any assholes opinion with any gear things that if you've come
out and said something,
have you,
do you think you've changed people's opinions?
I think opinions change if they value what you're saying,
if they believe that you're being truthful and if what you're saying is
compelling enough for them to reconsider the way they look at things,
it is possible,
but it's not 100% and it's not the motivation behind doing things in the first
place.
I'm not trying,
I don't ever try to change people's opinions,
but I do try to express myself as cleanly and as accurately and as honestly as I
can.
And I think that in my opinion,
in my experience,
when I've heard people like you talking about your life,
like you just talking about your life in this podcast,
I take that in and I know it's pure and it will make me consider every little,
every thing that a person says,
every sentence,
every conversation that you have with someone where they're being real with you,
it adds more knowledge to your database of human interaction and the way people
behave and think.
Now thinking that way,
it does slowly make you consider more things about people.
And that adds to the overall surface area of knowledge that you have about
people in general.
I that absolutely.
Do you in your position,
because you have considerable influence,
do you worry about having people kind of latch on things,
hive minded and,
and,
and go a direction,
but do you feel a responsibility,
I guess to people?
Right.
But definitely feel responsibility and not manipulating them and it definitely
feel responsibility and not taking advantage of that and not starting a cult or
something like that.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
but it's,
the good part about it is if you don't need anything from anybody,
like you're not trying to get people to send you $50 a month for the fucking,
you know,
platinum plan where you get access to the secret messages or no l Ron Hubbard or
whatever.
Yeah.
But you know what I mean?
It's like you can take advantage of people in,
in certain ways.
And I think that the,
that that's a,
that's a real issue with any sort of hive mind thinking.
Right?
And I,
yeah,
I don't know where I get I this,
this is fascinating.
I,
I guess religion and things like that always troubled me and,
and that hive mind mentality that,
that,
that troubles me.
It troubles me that,
I mean to be honest,
it troubles me that Alex Jones was on hair or somebody who,
who kind of leads that sort of thing.
Yes.
But when Alex Jones is on here,
I think people got to understand Alice Jones way more after me getting him drunk
and stoned and have a talk about interdimensional child molesters.
Like you get to see a child like,
oh,
this is kind of like a half wacky show or he's also commenting on the craziness
of the world,
but you got to see who he really is.
What I,
the guy that I've known for almost 20 years,
like that's what I wanted to do.
By having them on,
like people are like,
why are you friends Doug?
I'm like,
watch,
watch what happens.
We'll get them fucked up.
We're going to have some fun.
And you'll realize like,
oh,
this guy is like,
he's kind of wacky.
Like half of what he's doing is almost like a show.
Right?
It's a band,
right?
Well it's like an engine.
It is and that's kind of him.
People are buying into that,
but what are they buying into that's false and what are they buying into?
That's true.
Unfortunately,
a lot of what Alex Jones has been presenting over these years is actually true.
I'm like,
what?
Like agent provocateurs,
like when they have peaceful protests,
they'll send in people to smash windows and they're wearing government issue
boots and they get rounded up and they don't wind up being prosecuted because
they were literally brought in by the police to turn a peaceful protest into a
violent protest.
Like the people that took over occupy Wall Street and undercover cops that were
doing all this fucking crazy,
chaotic,
violent shit to get people to move in and break up these camps and break up
these protests when they were all legal.
Alex Jones sort of expose all that stuff first
to support me.
And I don't want to be,
I actually don't want to be in this,
I'm not trying to be controversial,
honestly.
I'm just like,
no.
It's following conversation.
Express your,
when he puts his support behind people like Donald Trump,
who is actually pushing these sorts of agendas,
what sorts of the that the anti protesting,
like trying to change the laws so that you can run over protesters when there
peacefully and things like that.
I don't know whether he's changing the laws,
but these things are coming.
It's something,
uh,
it's,
it was constant or Michigan.
There's something like that.
They're trying to put a thing into dates and whatever it is.
Yeah,
I know.
And I,
I'm so bad because when I follow my train of thought,
then I can never have citations and it drives me bananas because I don't want to
present information as speculation.
Right?
The people are trying to stop people from violating other people's rights.
Right.
But is a person's right to drive a car down the street more important than a
person's right to express themselves by saying,
I don't want this to happen.
I am willfully challenging the law right here in a peaceful way,
but it's not peaceful.
If your GRANDPA's dying and it needed to get to the hospital and some asshole
wants to stand in front of him with a macrame hat on with a,
you know,
I'm a male feminist sign,
right?
Are you quoting specifically talking about blocking people on the road?
It doesn't help anyone.
It doesn't help anybody.
I mean,
I've been arrested for political protests before and I was very aware.
I was crossing a line on to here I was doing something.
I was going to be arrested for it,
but it was the voices behind me and the collective voices together that we're
doing something not knowing that they were going to be arrested.
Knowing that the part about going to jail and being able to write about or being
able to understand that you are taking a stance on something.
You're just trying to bring attention to something that you think is wrong.
Oh,
it was many years ago and all the military guys already hate me,
but it was the school of the Americas.
I was 18.
I got arrested twice,
18 or 19.
Um,
it was a school in America is when they were,
they were teaching the counterinsurgency techniques,
um,
down at Fort Benning,
Georgia.
I'm banned for life there,
but it was very religious.
Then I was very into social justice.
I was really like,
I wanted to be a nun and I wanted to change the world and I wanted people to not
kill each other anymore.
And I wanted us not to fund military groups in South America who were
slaughtering people at the same time.
It was protesting.
I was stepping deliberately onto a military base and saying,
no,
I don't want this to happen anymore.
I'm peaceful.
You gonna go with you.
I,
you're arresting me.
I know my rights and the,
and,
okay,
so let's unpack that.
What you did there was you made a,
you up,
there's a political protest.
You went to the scene of where you think these terrible things are taking place
and you took a stand knowing you were going to get arrested and that it was
going to bring media attention to this.
There's a big difference between that and you deciding we're going to block the
one oh one because black lives matter,
you know,
that doesn't have anything to do with all those people that were driving to
work.
You're violating their rights to pass.
You're violating their space.
You're stopping them from being able to move freely and a lot of them are
private deal of attention to it.
You're doing it in a way that inconveniences and puts people in danger and it's
not necessary.
You can do it in a public space.
You could do it in places where you're allowed to protest.
You can do it and you could still get your voice out and still get your message
out and not block traffic on the highway.
The blocking traffic on the highways,
attention Horing and it's attention whoring in a very dangerous way because you
are stopping people from getting to medication.
You're stopping people from getting medical treatment.
Your people can be in the middle of giving birth.
There's a lot of shit that happens.
We you,
you fuck with people's ability to travel and move around,
we rely on that.
It's extremely significant.
So when you just decide that you know,
you,
whatever,
I want transgender rights for the bathroom,
let's block this fucking highway.
Just because you think you can get attention.
Doing something like that doesn't mean it's the right thing to do.
There are ways to get attention doing things that are lawful and there's ways
that are noble and then there's blocking the fucking highway like a baby.
Are they still working though?
I'm not just talking about in a highway.
The are are,
are bringing attention to things.
I mean is that still working the Dakota pipeline and stuff like that when people
were protesting in a peaceful way,
did it shut it down?
Shut it down,
but it just,
it's bad for Sam has changed.
It's not,
and I don't even know if that's the best example of it.
Good example because it was peaceful protesting and it did get a lot of
attention,
including me and a lot of other people who protest,
who tweeted about it and put a blinks about it and let people know about and
talked about it on the podcast.
Yeah,
I mean it does get attention.
The the tower,
I get it.
I understand what you're saying and I'm not protesting.
They're disregarding what you're saying about the highways and stuff like that
because that wouldn't be the kind of protest that I would want to be a part of.
This not the kind of thing I would want to enact.
Now did I believe in,
do I believe in the black lives matter movement?
Yes,
to a certain extent.
I also believe in police officer training and better training for police
officers and those in situations of high stress.
I think that there's so much nuance to what's going on there and there's so much
carried on and and the the highway blocking and the stuff like that.
You're giving very,
very good counter arguments to,
to this.
But I will say that there's also something in effect when you can make the
loudest noise
and you know something is wrong,
isn't it?
Your responsibility to try and fix things,
not by stopping the highway.
Maybe not,
maybe not.
Maybe it's not.
So by stopping the highway,
but if people are so determined to be against what you're saying there.
So in,
in Rudy,
you people have to make noise in the strangest ways they have to do what
people are very self righteous and they think that you have to listen to them
and you don't want to listen to them.
No,
you don't want to,
right.
As an American to not have to listen to someone's protest as much as it's your
right as an American,
a protest.
It is.
You can't force someone to listen to you because you think you're right.
And that's what you're doing by standing in front of someone on the highway in
blocking their passage.
Okay.
But getting beyond the highway thing,
because again,
what you're bringing on,
I have an issue with,
okay.
Okay.
Real literally,
I have no problem with protesting I think.
But when you protesting on the highway and you're blocking traffic,
you're a cunt.
I mean that's a shitty way to do it.
I,
I cannot disagree with you to a certain extent where it is a very inconvenient
thing and it can be a dangerous thing.
And I don't think any protesting should endanger peoples lives at all.
By the way.
I don't hate marathons too for the same reason.
Yeah.
Well I mean it makes a lot of sense.
Those are scheduled.
I don't think that that's um,
caused to be able to have the right to,
to run somebody over and kill me.
No,
you shouldn't have the right to life is not worth something because they're
expressing themselves in a way that you disagree with.
No,
but that's not necessarily what the law is saying.
No law saying that you someone responsibility if someone jumps in front of your
car and tries to stop you that we've seen,
he brings Saul people smashed their car windows because they're trying to get
through some sort of a protest line and they don't have anything to do with what
the protest is.
They just want to get out of there.
I were in their car and their stock and maybe they have their kid with them and
the kids crying and freaking out and they hit the gas.
Incredibly
detailed.
This is an incredibly detailed example of some that I don't actually have the
reference point to.
I don't have a citation for this,
so I can't argue with you on any of the story that you're giving me because I
have no way of knowing this,
this incident,
but I do think that your speculation is correct in,
in the sense that I think that no,
that would be horrible.
That would be horrible to have people saying,
okay,
this means more to me.
Then you're getting your kid to your sick kid to the hospital.
I think absolutely.
I think that that,
no,
I don't think that anybody's life is worth more than another person's life.
What's also,
there's something going on with,
there's a lot of misdirected rage and anger.
Like my friend was very angry.
My friend was at one of these things where he was trying to get his car through
and they were all blocked and stopped and people had crossed hands,
locked hands and blocked the highway and some guy came up to his window and is
screaming,
black lives matter,
screaming at his window.
He's like,
yeah,
I agree man.
Okay,
I'm a great,
but I'm stuck in traffic.
Why are you yelling at me?
I'm not doing anything like were very angry right now because like this white
guy yelling at him,
another white guy and he's screaming,
black lives matter at him.
It's like,
okay,
this is so misdirected.
If my friend is a Democrat,
votes liberal,
he's so,
so liberal,
like down the board with a pretty much everything and someone's screaming at him
and screaming at him like he has done something wrong because this person is
misguided and misdirected rage and they're,
they're a part of this whole mob mentality.
Everyone's together,
they're all chanting and yelling and everyone's getting excited and they think
that they're doing the right thing.
And these kids today,
a lot of them that are involved in these protests,
they're so enamored by this idea that they're doing the right thing.
They're enacting change.
They don't realize that they're also polarizing the opposition,
and this is one of the reasons why Donald Trump was elected in the first place
because so many people are so tired of people shoving in their face.
They're righteous indignation shoving in their face is locking hands and
blocking the highway and you have to listen to us.
That is energy and it goes like this.
And then when it goes like that,
people go like that.
It's in and out.
There's a cycle.
And can you understand where the rage is built up of?
People felt like they've been ignored and they've been pushed back so hard that
they actually start exploding like that and they get into these hives cause they
have
no other group to belong to.
There's definitely a way that you could see that.
There's definitely a way that makes sense.
I guess what is the appropriate way to do things?
The way to do,
to continue to write,
to continue to talk,
to continue to express yourself in a way that's going to make other people
consider what you're saying and maybe change people's minds and thoughts and,
and it's not an instantaneous thing.
That's the problem.
Not like you put up a sign and everything's fixed.
No,
we turned his tone.
We are a society that um,
right.
Well I think that's part of the rage of people screaming as they want it to
change now and by going up to my friend's window and yelling,
black lives matter this fuck.
Head thinks he's going to change,
but he's doesn't even really think that.
He thinks he's got the right to do it.
And you've got to fucking listen to me,
man.
There's this thing going on where people get these mob mindsets where they think
they're allowed to hit a girl because she's got a red hat on that says make
bitcoin great again.
Have you seen that video?
That poor girl got maced in the face?
Horrible was a Joe cat.
They may stir in the fucking face.
I get that.
I get what you're saying.
And I'm,
I'm,
I am on board with,
with the sentiment of what you're saying.
I really do understand it,
but I also think there's such a,
a finger pointing going on and I'm guilty of it on my Twitter because I go after
these fuck heads all the time.
They call it usually.
Yeah,
you Feminazi and I say,
no,
fuck Donald Trump.
Seriously,
that person is not qualified to be president.
Well,
Hillary's bad too.
It was like,
that's not,
I didn't say anything about Hillary.
I said,
this person in office is not qualified.
He should step down.
Um,
but I,
and can I really wanted to be president?
No,
I don't think he wanted to be president at all.
Yeah.
No,
I think he's terrified.
He is a scared,
terrified little man up there.
He's not terrified.
Maybe he's crazy,
but he,
I don't think you wanted to do this.
It's just sort of happen.
Yeah.
I think,
I think he didn't think it through and I think that's when we're talking about
not thinking it through.
I think the guy screaming at your friend in the window,
he's not thinking it through.
He's caught on to something.
He's caught up in a wave of something.
There's a million other people behind them.
Everyone's screaming,
he's looking at my friend,
my friend's vulnerable,
my friends below him cause he's seated and he's just screaming.
Yeah,
black lives matter.
Black lives matter.
It's like,
okay.
Yeah.
And it's that bullshit.
But it's it.
It's also about Twitter generation protesting eight,
you know?
But it's also,
we have learned,
it's so hard to just generalize and say everything is because of this and
everything is because of that,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Everything has to come from an individual place and at the same time,
we're all trying to belong to communities.
We're all trying to belong to something we believe in,
right.
And,
and we're latching onto that.
And then I think that the sins that happen in the sense that we would ever then
that happened along the way,
the missteps that happened along the way,
we tend to forgive them instead of pointing out,
no,
you shouldn't do this.
You shouldn't affect somebody who's driving their child to work or something
like that.
But that's not what should happen.
But we do tend to forgive the people who are in the same team as us.
Don't wait,
of course.
And that's where the,
the make America great fuckers.
Sorry.
I think,
well we did you go out of that,
they can't see their team lose and they'll defend him now to the death of defend
his decisions.
He does something wrong.
Well,
you don't understand how it works,
do you?
No,
I actually,
I do understand how it works.
This person is not supposed to be in power.
This person's not supposed to represent America.
This is,
and,
and he is,
and he's not who I want the world to see America as.
I think we're a great country and we fuck up a lot.
Yeah.
This is also a problem when having a popularity contest to decide who gets to
run things.
Imagine if they had a popularity contest to get to see who the dean of Harvard.
Yeah.
Like what's a corrector going to be this year?
The curriculum is going to be Jesus.
All right.
I will,
I need,
that's what's going to be happening right now are getting do away with the
public.
All the vouchers and the shit that's happening.
There's a lot of weird shit on a Jeff sessions.
Guy Scares her shit.
Oh my God.
He wants to bring back,
just say no.
Yeah.
My spring back to 19 he's just saying he,
okay.
He just said,
and the marijuana has the same negative effects is heroin,
which slightly less bad than heroin.
What the Hell Dude,
like child,
an old child and it's,
yeah,
it's not good.
No,
And,
and I,
I,
cause I get worked up thinking about it,
but do you know about these people in power?
And I got it.
As you get worked out and people get worked up rather,
and they start talking about it and they also realize that,
hey man,
it really does matter if you vote,
it really does matter if you're politically active,
right.
It really doesn't matter if you talk about these things that you care,
but the team mentality that we have,
the US versus them,
it just gets so weird.
It gets so fucking crazy.
People get so out of control with it and they,
like you said,
they the people that make America great again,
people they don't want to hear shit about the left.
They didn't want to hear shit about Bernie.
They want to say Barack Obama's a Muslim and from fucking Kenya
and I'm guilty of not wanting to know good things about Donald Trump.
Yeah,
I don't want to know them.
I don't care.
I don't,
I don't care because I see so much.
You know?
It's just like there's so much that's working against human achievement with him
being in power and the people he's appointing,
empower.
It is
think it gives people a goal.
I think it gives people like,
I think without opposition it's very difficult to get motivated.
And I think there's a significant amount of opposition now.
And people were,
I think they're organizing people on the left are organizing in a way that they
never have before.
And hopefully,
hopefully people understand their,
there'll be someone along the line that understands that the polarization effect
that happens between choosing these hard line teams left and right,
and not recognizing the possibility that there's so many people in the middle
that just pick a side.
They just decided to go left or decided to go.
Right.
And they could be on either side,
but both of them are unreasonable.
Both of them are unrealistic.
Yeah.
You know,
and yeah,
Hillary Clinton was a terrible candidate.
She was a terrible opposition candidate.
Hopefully next time they'll be someone that's really good and will understand
what is the problem with having a medical maniacal Egomaniac who a fucking,
uh,
a business vulture run,
run the country.
Yeah.
Which happened,
I mean,
that was the choice.
This one and this like,
you know,
okay.